[Music]  in 2018 sharif o'neill didn't know if  he'd be able to continue playing  basketball due to a rare heart condition  yesterday sharif signed a six-figure  contract with the g-league ignite when  sharif was a child doctors told the  o'neills that he had a little ablation  in his heart but they were also told  year after year that sharif is fine and  should just carry on with his life in  2018 the o'neills get a call saying that  sharif has a very dangerous and serious  abnormality in his heart and that he's  had it all along sharif had been living  his life that in any moment he could  have had a heart attack and possibly  died the doctors told the o'neills that  sharif would need open heart surgery the  surgery itself had many risks and some  people who shared the same condition  would even opt out of the surgery  because of them but sharif knew he  wanted to play basketball and he also  knew that in order to do that he would  need the surgery it was a success and  now he's here